listen I loved this movie
um and you guys are both I think uh both
newbies to the franchise
um and getting to
um what was what actually surprised you
about joining a franchise like this in
the way Chris and Tom work because the
way they collaborate is unique amongst a
lot of filmmakers and actors well go
ahead you take these you'd collaborated
with them
um you know this was
fairly different this is very different
from from Top Gun and filming I think
since they've done Mission Impossible
you know like two or three times before
they had this type of Rapport and they
know each other like the back of their
hands is very interesting to see when
McHugh was saying something like hey Tom
I need you and Tom is already like yep I
got it and he does it and it's just like
wait we didn't he did he said no he
didn't or or Thomas like hey McHugh I
think is it already on it I told him to
put the camera right there and he's like
thank you cue got it they just know what
they're doing you know I mean you and I
have known each other from small films
you know independent films you come on
something like this but it it it it's
huge these things the the the the the
the the uh tapestry is huge but you
still they love story and they love
character so you get in there and I was
shocked how much we delved into
character and story and they give each
character a moment in this piece you
know so I love that aspect of it I love
that Tom Embraces the fact that he's
been running in movies since like 86 or
96 whatever it is you guys get to run in
this movie
um talk a little I mean but you have the
train sequence which is insane and then
you also have the Abu Dhabi airport
sequence which is incredible so which
one for both of you were you I guess
more nervous to film or more excited to
film because both are memorable probably
the train sequence because that was the
first thing we we shot was on top of the
train and you know you come in for the
first day of filming for both of us and
it's like hey guys go on top of a train
it's like oh okay yeah we joining sign
up for this of course yeah yeah I mean
that but you left out Venice because
Venice is what we did the most running
yeah I mean although we we hooked it
pretty hard through the airport there
now it does but that was the one because
we were shooting Knights I remember and
uh we were we were running all night
from like 9 00 P.M to 6 a.m and that was
the one where I pulled something on the
last night of like a weekday shoot
pulled a pulled a calf muscle remember
that yes I told you I went I said the
toilet I said I don't I don't have
another one in me and MyQ comes up he
says listen so I didn't get that you got
another one in you
and this is not the Hollywood speak like
I really had popped it and we I said you
said yeah let's let's just try to get in
and we we went again and I I saw that
sequence the other night in the movie
and it was intense is really intense you
know beautiful stuff yeah also that uh
the not this wasn't involving the two of
you but that fight sequence in Venice
with Tom and the two of them in that
little alley is oh my God you know what
I mean it's just uh what I have to ask
for the two of you what actually was
your reaction watching the finished film
being inside of making something like
this because the spectacle is insane
it's it's huge when you're in it you're
so focused and and you have that that
laser being focused on what you're doing
you don't really know what everybody
else is doing and you start questioning
asking the queue like how is this all
going to tie together I don't get it
like it's not making sense to me this
big thing you have the old characters
you have the new characters coming in
how do you make it all come together and
you watch and it's like oh this is what
you were doing oh this is the genius
that you put on the screen for the
audience to watch and be entertained and
he did a fantastic job with it yeah I
walked out
I tape I texted McHugh and Tom and him I
went proud like I'm proud of this piece
the last 40 minutes I couldn't I
couldn't I held my breath last week and
I knew what was going to happen and I
was still you know I just think it's I
think it's a brilliant action film
with characters you care about I was
saying to people when the movie ended
this might have been the fastest two and
a half hour movie I've seen in forever
like it just it it just never slows down
and you want more after yeah yeah
speaking of more
um what are you allowed to tease about a
certain part too there's a part two I
believe there might be actually
oh well some money to get my agents on
that then God dang I don't know I don't
know I've just found another about this
I thought it was only a part one yeah uh
McHugh I had a long interview with mchu
this morning he said that uh they're
still you guys are gonna be filming till
early next year
um and uh yeah I heard rumors although I
don't know how big your character's
involvement is in the sequel obviously
well that's news to me early next year
that is news to me okay I'll move on so
you don't have to get one of the things
though I think that it's it's crazy is
when when McHugh and Eric are working on
the screenplay years ago they couldn't
have known how much AI would be talked
about when this movie is coming out I
mean it's like a little
nostradamus-esque in terms of you know
because you wrote this four years ago or
so talk a little bit about that aspect
that it's very like exactly in the
moment this movie yeah it was pretty
appreciated when you look back I mean we
didn't know you know what I mean but the
thing with those guys is it it's story
they hooked into a story
but I I don't want to get too caught up
even in the AI at all because they these
guys want to entertain at the end of the
day they want they want you to come into
the theater and to watch this and be
entertained and then that happens to be
something that they you know they you
know they they latched on to and it it
just happens to now be you know in the
Forefront agreed I mean look I mean I
think it's I think it's interesting uh
maybe that maybe they can see into the
future oh 100 all right I gotta rap I'm
just gonna say seriously congratulations
movie is awesome thank you